Water
Earth
Fire
Air
Welcome back everyone happy holidays we just
found out what the new animated avatar The Last
Airbender series is going to be or the First
new series it confirms a lot of our theories
there's also a lot of news about the upcoming
animated movies that they're in the middle of
making right now and the new live-action Netflix
series so we'll break it all down if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos I will be doing more Avatar videos this
year just because a lot of stuff is happening they
will actually start premiering those live-action
Netflix episodes too good or bad whatever winds up
happening with that I'll at least do some videos
for that but that's like a completely separate
thing from Avatar studios in the animated avatar
The Last Airbender series and movies that Mike and
Bryan are making I'm expecting the new live-action
Netflix series to Premiere either towards the end
of the summer or later this year so we'll probably
get a trailer in the next couple of months but
the really good news you probably just saw in
your feeds is that Mike and Bryan's first new
remember this first new but not last new animated
avatar The Last Airbender series is now confirmed
to be about the next Avatar after akora moving the
timeline forward the same way that Korra just came
after Aang The Avatar cycle goes fire air water
and Earth so when Mike and Bryan first announced
that they were making new animated Avatar movies
and series most of us just speculated that they'd
logically just move the timeline forward and
do the next Avatar after Korra which would be
an earthbender avatar but they are also doing
stuff earlier in the timeline too like they'll
be jumping all over the timeline and a bunch of
different types of projects I'll explain later
in the video but the new Full regular animated
series will just pick up after Korra has died in
the new earthbender Avatar is born they have it
announced who the person's name is or if it's
going to be a female or a male Avatar but if
you've been following the story of Korra in the
comics that explains what happens to her after
the events of the finale her lifespan is meant to
be fairly typical of the majority of all avatars
meaning she lived Beyond 100 years old which you
would consider like a slightly longer lifespan
for a really healthy person living past 100 in the
Avatar Universe isn't uncommon for regular people
the only major exceptions to how long avatars
live are when they're either killed in battle like
killed under mysterious circumstances or the most
famous examples being Avatar Kyoshi and Avatar
Aang Aang died when he was 66 chronologically
and at the time it was considered a very early
death in terms of his year spent walking around
like chronologically but biologically he died
at the age of 166 because he was stuck in the ice
for over 100 years and being in the Avatar state
for that long just took a huge toll on his body
had that not happened he would have just lived
a normal lifespan well past 100 years the other
exception like on the other end of that is Kyoshi
who lived way longer than most avatars she was
about 200 years old when she died but she was a
beast she was also just physically way bigger than
most people one of the new animated movies that
they're doing is a kyoshi movie I'll talk about
that later in the video so they are doing a lot
of new Kyoshi stuff too but the idea is that this
new earthbender Avatar series after Korra would
pick up about a hundred years after the quora
finale close to or at real world present day like
a modern day Avatar like a lot of people wondered
that they would do so the idea is that during the
events of Korra Republic City for example had a
very Roaring 20s inspired Vibe with the design
and the level of Technology the way bending had
evolved this new series would look more like our
real world present day like an avatar walking
around with our current level of Technology but
remember this is the Avatar universe so it's not
always like a one-to-one comparison like the best
example being will this new Avatar be the one who
walks around with an iPhone in his or her pocket
like The Tick Tock Avatar please don't put Tick
Tock in the Avatar Universe we could do without
that this is where I think Mike and Bryan will
change a couple things like the current period
in the Avatar universe will just be similar in
the way science starts to rival traditional use
of bending elements like during the events of
Legend of Korra their big thing was showing that
just 50 years plus after avatar The Last Airbender
Society had evolved to start harnessing lightning
bending powers to generate electricity people like
kuvira began to harness Spirit energy taken from
the vines in the world tree using them to power
weapons and Technology people like bayfong were
using their metal bending abilities to power
their technology for crime fighting like not
just their tactics but also their armor their
Weaponry what we'll probably see is more of
that kind of thinking like scientists in the
future of the Avatar Universe finding new ways
of exploiting bending energy cosmic energy from
the spirit world for weapons for technology even
for just regular everyday stuff that non-benders
use and take advantage of they started to get into
this idea during chorus season 4 where some people
have started to harvest abuse Spirit energy cosmic
energy the spirit world started to fight back
the spirits themselves the biological life that
originated there like the vines that started to
take over Republic City even though Korra pacified
kuvira in the finale and her weapon the whole idea
is that she opened a new permanent portal to the
spirit realm and for public city so travel between
the spirit realm and the regular world became much
more common and that wasn't meant to be the end
of the conflict like everybody does not live in
peace after that people are always going to try
and use resources like that to exploit the spirit
world bending to personal gain exploit just a
regular World in general exploit the earth like
imagine an avatar Series where everybody's using
iPhones just because it's Modern Day level of
Technology but they're powered by Spirit energy
and it turns out that that's basically sucking
the energy out of the spirit world slowly killing
it so in the way the chorus Series in general had
started to get into the balance between bending
and Technology a modern day Avatar series would
be all about that like what happens to bending
if Science and Technology gives everyone the
same level of abilities that comes with being a
bender if not greater abilities like the other
cool thing being that every time they do Advance
the timeline the Avatar universe is that bending
in general just evolves as people come up with
more creative ways to use their bending Powers
you start to see even more specialized forms of
sub bending tough is one of the best examples a
regular earthbender who discovered metal bending
or created Mendel bending fire bending evolving
into lightning bending so that will continue in
this new series too let me know in the comments
what kind of sub styles of bending do you want
to see just based on what we've already seen
from sub bending Styles remember it'd be like even
more specialized forms of sub bending for example
electricity bending evolving to the level where
they can bend electrical signals inside machines
controlling machines with their bending like you
would control a puppet an avatar who could control
your phone because of the way they can manipulate
electrical signals flowing through it vendors who
can control the weather also the whole idea that
scientists in the Avatar Universe can find a way
to clone bending abilities using technology
so that non-benders could just wear gear that
allows them to bend one or multiple elements like
what does the Avatar do when anyone can bend all
four elements or anyone can energy Bend which
is supposed to be like the most s-tier form of
bending that's hard for even avatars to do I know
there's also a big question about the way avatars
access their previous lives because during the
events of Korra unalak essentially destroyed
her access to the previous lives with vatu's
dark Avatar Powers after that Korra never got
access to those previous avatars again she could
only speak with rabba which was something that
previous avatars weren't supposed to be able
to do like maybe a few you were able to but in
general when Korra did it it was thought to be
a relatively new thing like rava had always been
there inside the other avatars but you never hear
about Aang chatting it up with rabba meaning that
when this new earthbender Avatar comes along a
hundred years later he'd only be able to speak
with Korra Spirit or rava unless they introduced
some new weird wrinkle to the way Avatar Powers
work right now the target release date is the
end of 2025 right after the new animated avatar
The Last Airbender movie comes out so you kind
of see what they're doing here they're going to
try and release that new movie in October 2025 and
then like right after that the series picks up but
the First new animated Avatar movie is going to be
about older Aang and the older avatar characters
from The Last Airbender after the events of
the finale but they haven't said whether or
not they're going to cover things that they've
already done in the comics maybe some things but
probably not exactly one-to-one copies of what
they did in the comics if you haven't read any
of those the comics basically tell you exactly
what happens to them right after the finale like
Aang in fire lord Zuko create Republic City or
they start creating republics that he takes away
while to build it Azula comes back to harass Zuko
doing exactly what you would expect adult Azula
to do they explain who toff's baby daddies are she
had two different baby daddies and they explained
what happened to Zuko's mother I've already done
a couple videos about all that stuff so I'll post
links for that stuff in the description below the
new Avatar series will run at the same time as the
live-action Netflix series but the live-action
Netflix episodes are just retelling the events
of the original avatar The Last Airbender animated
series with Aang and by the time the new animated
series premieres will be in like season 2 of the
live action series I'm only expecting that new
Netflix series to run for a couple Seasons they
haven't said how many seasons the new animated
series will run probably like three or four like
Korra did and while that's happening every two or
every three years they'll release a new animated
Avatar movie they've already announced three
movies total the first one is with the adult gang
but the second two are Azuka movie and a kyoshi
movie they didn't say which order they're going
to do them in but I'm assuming right now it starts
with the Avatar The Last Airbender movie about the
whole gang because they've confirmed that then the
Zuko movie and then the Kyoshi movie there will
be more animated movies and more animated series
after these first ones from Mike and Bryan that
probably won't talk about the other stuff till
after later seasons of this first new one though
so like this is meant to be the beginning of a
big Avatar Universe of shows from all across the
timeline so when you're all old and gray then you
have like great grandchildren you'll be telling
them about the original Avatar series as the new
one gets ready to Premiere like ah the 10th new
Avatar series can't wait to talk about it it'll
be a lot of fun they've also said they're evolving
or changing the animation style for the upcoming
movie they'll probably do the same thing for the
Avatar TV series as well they did say that they
wanted all their upcoming projects like all the
different movies in the series to all feel and
look very different but they did say the first
upcoming movie will feature computer assisted
animation in the style of Spider-Man into the
spider-verse like that kind of computer assisted
animation is coming from the same Studio that
also animated rise of the Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles which actually has pretty solid animation
the Netflix account was teasing some Avatar stuff
so they might make some more announcements or drop
a teaser video for that new live-action Netflix
series pretty soon whatever they wind up releasing
of course they'll do a video for it everyone click
here for my Loki season 2 trailer video and click
here for that new Henry Cavill Warhammer trailer
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!